good morning millennium good morning
Millennials welcome back to the morning
toast it's only Tuesday
oh my god that shakes me to my core that
is our [ __ ] cross to bear this week
tonight it is I was in bed and I was
like well at least tomorrow's Wednesday
no no no I love that we still have that
ribbon from your birthday on our table I
mean we're just a celebratory bunch I'm
wearing a chartreuse shirt you wish I
don't know what show choices but they
finally sound using the word like in
everyday life and you know what I never
want to find out what chartreuse is
because just like then not knowing and
thinking that I'm wearing show truths is
just enough for me you know die you know
yeah but it is a beautiful shirt a
canary yellow is what it actually is
yeah canary yellow just makes me think
that I'm rich because I have a canary
yellow diamond so I'll take it
cool I have been like very into the
tucking in of my shirt to my pants
and I truly feel as even though like
this is actually like in my in recent
weeks like my actual cross the river
okay I think I know what it is because I
have been like loving the way that I've
just like been looking like talking my
shirts in like I've never in my life
touched my shirt and like since I was a
child like never and I've just been
really feeling the vibe but my true like
my cross to bear is like this style like
looks so good and then I turned to the
side and my Fupa it's like so
extraordinarily large and it's like it's
my clothes to wear because I feel one
way yeah I love like this businesswoman
special outfit that I'm wearing but then
I turn to the side I'm like oh like what
is this skin yeah I don't know that
seems like a closer maybe you need
energy well so I did a outreach on my
Instagram I was like what is the best
Fupa hiding pants and I got mixed
reviews nobody said the actual jeans
that I'm wearing so from Topshop so I
think that I need to move past I got a
lot of varieties for a zombie Fupa
inducing pad I think they are too cuz I
guess it of inducing juicing no I don't
know like okay I just want to say our PA
is taking a picture of us on her iPad
like what are you and Dad at a baseball
game we hired a gram
she brought our show because it's the
Millennial morning show but we're
inclusive of all ages I just like turned
to my right and there was someone I
literally felt like I was at my high
school volleyball game and like Josh
wilds dad had his iPad out and was
recording it hey I'm just doing what you
had in the picture I didn't get to take
it yet cuz then you called me out
I'm sorry Tasha Jason Abramson said went
with an iPad anywhere he also just
retired Congrats Alice also someone was
asking why the snitch was wearing air
pods the whole show because that says
snitching to pretend like she's not even
paying attention
no but it's because she's listening to
the show also there was like a lot of
hoopla about the way you wear your ear
pods like I just saw I know I know I'm
upset I don't know what to do
differently like I think Betty that's
better like you were wearing them like
with an outstretched arm that's how I
wear mine and I prefer it like I don't
need them like sure thing no because
like I don't like the fact that like air
pods are supposed to if you have your
hair and I'm like people won't see that
you're wearing air pods no supposed to
talk to you like I think I'd like to
about the string around my neck with
there with the regular headphones it's
like people know don't [ __ ] talk to
me yeah and air pods have now eliminated
that to you to wear it in the most like
insane way so people know not to talk to
you I just wear your hair by your ears
and look like Taylor why um anyways I
also wanted to discuss the fact that you
and I went through similar traumatic
experiences yes I was trying to explain
the Tibetan here like didn't think it
was funny
well I didn't have to explain his act
because he saw my Instagram story and
your sabai the time oh so you have a
supportive husband I don't have one of
those at home he was like uh he was in
on the joke yeah and he did think it was
really funny because it was really funny
because I I just I would never thought
it like to say anything about it like I
didn't speak up like yeah why not I
thought it was such a weird thing that
happened to me that like I had to speak
up you can follow us on Instagram I went
through a weird thing yesterday where
when we left the show Jackie was like I
am not feeling good but I want to eat
pasta and just like take care of myself
so then it got me all inspired to have
pasta and I was laying in my bed doing
like emails and just like having phone
calls like really just feeling like back
and forth like should I have the pasta
or not like I wanted pops it so bad but
I'm really trying to be good especially
like I think I might be pregnant so like
I really need to stop eating doesn't the
time to start that's true
so I needs to eat I was like finally I'm
gonna do it and I called Serafina which
is like might go to pasta place they
literally only serve pasta and I placed
an order on seamless and two seconds
after I clicked like place order I got a
phone call from the restaurant basically
just being like okay like we don't have
today and I'm like so how are you even
open like it's literally all they
started was the weirdest thing and I
just thought it was a weird experience
to share my Instagram story then once I
did Jackie [ __ ] was blowing me up on
Instagram being like oh my god literally
the same exactly happen to me because I
said I was gonna order pizza house and
in that moment I didn't know that I was
going to us until I said it to you and
it sounded really good but I was
literally same experience I'm like that
emailing all day like working from home
and I was like I kind of want like that
did sound good when I said it you know
what I deserve it finally order it pizza
two pastas because I can never decide
between the Pomodoro and the penne alla
vodka and they call me and they're like
we don't have two of the items and I was
like my item so like we don't we're not
having pasta today I was like the
restaurants are having pasta and I
figured it was like so not possible that
I was like okay either cancel the order
if you don't have what to send me or
just whatever they never cancelled the
order but I was like someone didn't
understand on the phone like they're
definitely have classic really oh sorry
I'm taking I still have not even halfway
to where you were no I don't know but
you like some breeze right through it no
you did not yeah it has like a whole
train of thought I just looked up and I
thought about what is you you [ __ ]
started it Alizee it's not about what
I'm talking about the pasta for five
minutes I came in I talked to you think
Margaux Thomas who was talking about the
same story yeah you took five minutes
that gives me at least five minutes oh
my god I literally said it's so fast
like Margo
who said it fast am I getting involved
because you want to see tomorrow cuz you
were ten I am oh just monitoring the
comments just doing my job
thank you for saying thank you Europe
your platforming your time no I was
gonna die I didn't want to interrupt you
I wish you would continue I just wanted
to point out I was like and she's still
talking about the bolsa no way you were
talking for longer I don't think that's
the case anyways I didn't get my pasta
but you got a pizza and I got nothing I
just got a pizza I eat the whole thing
and I guess that's what happens when you
don't get pasta because you should I
just have two slices for and it was
pretty delicious just like pizza on
deliveries I've never as good pasta can
really travel well that's true that's
really true and it's cold I like it cold
to almost as much
yeah like when it's been in the fridge
like for a few hours and it's like a
different it's a different meal no I
don't like cold pizza I really don't
like me I know I just like people like
love called pizza I don't like any of
that [ __ ] it's a hot food from a
restaurant like cuz that's so much to
ask
no but like I hate like cold pizza is
really sad and gross but cold pastas not
it's like pasta salad well then you can
reheat pasta and it can be just as good
if you reheat pizza like in the
microwave unless you have like an oven
like the whole thing it's never as good
yet though you don't know cuz there's
not one in my kitchen which is so weird
so we have to buy one and I just don't
know what kind of want to buy it like
nothing I know but we haven't like
organized our kitchen yet I need to so
you haven't spoken about on the toast
and try to got a free one you guys Jagga
needs a free microwave Smeg hit her up I
actually like I could I mean I'll always
take a free anything and I have a lot of
Smeg stuff but I don't know what my
color is you know mm-hmm
so I'm just between a rock and a hard
place counselor snitch what do you
recommend
what's your name thing it's mag Jeebs
Mac no I can't afford a swag but you
can't force me Oh microwave that's my
kitchen oh my god me and Marta went to
Best Buy yesterday it was absolute
torture and I told Margo I know that
there's this thing at Best Buy we're
like I mean when it comes to TVs I'm
just cheap because I feel like they
really like mark up the prices with like
these fake acolytes like it's ultra HD
4k and it's a clean it's a [ __ ] TV and
they're always just marking it up and
it's so unnecessary and so unfair so
they have a thing called open box you
know about it and not a lot of people
not above open box my first TV was open
back open boxes [ __ ] $80 for a TV so we
went over and then he was showing us all
the TVs and I'm like yo where's the list
of open box and he takes us to the
clipboard with the open boxes and
Marshall got a great like $7 TV for $300
and he said the only thing is this is a
brand-new TV someone returned to it
never used it but it they didn't return
the remote so like okay Mario bought
another about for $35 we're like we
really thought we scheme the system we
get back to Marcos apartment like I was
just so over like being helpful also
what about the fact that you and I were
dragging a pickup we carried it on our
backs to the streets of New York we get
upstairs Jackie it comes literally just
the screen no sand no remote no cables
to plug it into the wall it was
literally useless
turn it no I'm just gonna get the cables
oh wow
yeah but it's only one cable just a
power cord yeah cuz I'm not getting
cable yeah what are you getting YouTube
TV just no I don't need cable it's a
smart TV a smart TV all I do is watch
Netflix and Hulu so I get watch like TV
in the living room I will be able to but
for my room I thought there was a smart
economical choice of Margaret like she's
any cable on her bedroom I never watch
cable I could literally not have cable
in my living room and I wouldn't know or
care like it would just affect Ben
because I make a bunch of sports in
there but like I was seeing that the
other day how like I bought this big
couch because I was like I want to take
naps on my couch I literally never sit
on my couch I love my couch also
speaking of sports the shoots comes out
today I listened to their episode last
night they did the funniest thing
because you know like six kids won the
Spelling Bee know didn't know yeah like
these genius kids like they couldn't
pick a winner because they kept going
all the kids kept doing it so they did a
spelling bee of like all like like these
basketball players and it was so funny
it was really creative and cute new
episode 3 p.m. Eastern Time subscribe at
the sheds join the Switzer's Facebook
group at the Spitzer's and honestly like
becoming a Schwitzer is a great way to
get into the toasters I think once we
said that like so many people joined the
ship it says last night good yeah but I
figured out some backdoor ways to get
more people into the toasters because um
it's just like with like linked groups
so that's that's a little secret message
so they I've been doing that too no but
like I added more linked groups oh
that's smart that's really smart oh good
so anyways without further ado do you
think it's time to deliver the Fast Five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast sure okay
without further ado first story
something that happened this weekend
here is the update I thought it was an
interesting story full of interesting
factoids Diplo Joe Jonas apologize for
saying I quote ruined his wedding Joe
Jonas and Diplo are cool again the
sucker singer apologize to DJ after
joking on the UK radio show Capitol
breakfast with Roman Kemp that Diplo
quote ruined his wedding to sophie
Turner by live-streaming the ceremony on
Instagram quote he called me today to
apologize Diplo said on on Air with Ryan
Seacrest Monday
adding that Jonas said quote in England
they love the drama
Jonas previously said quote I love Diplo
but he loves his Graham more than a
thirteen-year-old
he posts every five seconds
literally like live streamed with
dog-faced filters the electricity artist
said he and Jonas wanted to continue
their beef as a joke but he might have
spoiled their plans by releasing that
information reflecting on Jonah Center
no surprise nuptials Diplo added I
didn't know was a serious wedding I
really didn't know what was going on I
was hanging out with him after the
Billboard Awards and I was like this is
crazy
on May first a couple Ted not in front
of an Elvis impersonator and small group
of friends in a Las Vegas wedding chapel
that's hilarious that he said he loves
his Instagram more than a 13-year old
and when I saw the story unfolding I
really couldn't tell if it was real or
not
because I did ruin his wedding and the
Diplo responding like those in a Bruin
wedding was outfit like I didn't know if
this was serious or not because it
seemed like it a little jealous and so
if he had a legitimate gripe with Diplo
yeah and I was hoping that it wasn't
because the fact that Diplo livestream
it like made it even better it would
have been the chance like nobody ever
knew about and they could have like kept
this sacred moment if it weren't for
didn't know but if that's what they were
trying to do or like some people like
posted like dad and shaped perform like
some of it would have been in the news
but they wouldn't have the whole thing
like it really felt like we were all
there which was such a gift for us but
probably like a little bit annoying for
them and it would have been like more
secretive secretive and exclusive it
Diplo had it live stream the PA wants to
make a point she's raising her hand I
watched the interview where Joe Jonas
said that in who's fully speak sarcastic
and joking okay so that's a thing like
when people transcribe like interviews
on radio or like TV to like news outlets
you can never like sense the tone no you
can sense the tone and that's where I
feel the media industry is lacking and
they feel as though that's their cross
to bear as do i they have a lot of
crosses to bear
yeah and this is just there's one of
many well speaking of I watched chasing
happiness and so did Margo so at the end
of this episode Jackie's going to excuse
herself and Margo is going to sit down
because I have so many thoughts that if
I don't get them out like I will be like
pregnant full of thoughts and it's not
like it's like a finale of Game of
Thrones where it's full of spoilers but
it's like I want to come to my own
thoughts on my own with brushes and then
see if we had the same thing yeah you
know that's always an interesting things
you do it now that we have a PA who's
you know a body in a chair I can step
out and PA can step in I ready for our
next story which is like something that
I didn't realize happen but happened
sure Governors Ball Kaos left
concertgoers quote scared for their life
you know what's so funny is I had no
idea about this until I saw something go
ball like really sustained
I like they were reacting to pandemonium
but I didn't hear about the pan Bonilla
no me neither as the clouds clear after
storms wrecked Sunday's Governor's Ball
Music Festival the full extent of the
chaos on Randall's Island is coming to
light we're told there was a near riot
as organizers called off the show at
9:30 p.m.
before headliners The Strokes took the
stage and hordes of teenagers scramble
to get out one social media user claimed
people were quote legitimately scared
for their lives people were jumping the
fences and barricades and rushing the
buses one attendee tells page six it got
scary because people felt desperate one
person commented on social media quote
my fave performance of Gov ball is the
crowd of people who knocked down this
giant fence so we could get the [ __ ] off
this island one group got into a
confrontation with security after the
rowdy crowds started dismantling an art
installation but what we carried out
freaking out about okay so I guess they
I guess there was a big storm rain was
driving thunder lightning um and they
called off the show so all of a sudden
everyone has is just trying to leave an
island at the exact same time and it's
just a madhouse
they don't have the infrastructure to
get everyone out at all at once because
usually I festival exits are staggering
it seems like the crowd is being
incredibly dramatic like there was no
threat no but the threat is like your
fellow people it's like Lord of the
Flies fire festival there's no threat at
fire festival other than you know
someone coming and [ __ ] a tent just
seems like people are being it's just
like human nature they just go into
panic mode I mean this is why like I
just can't go to festivals like let
alone gov ball it's just like the whole
island thing is just not for me no and
it's like if I'm going to an island it's
not gonna be like off of New York City
right and you know what's so sad about
like situations like this it's like this
is where true elitism kicks Inc it's
like you know the artists we're totally
fine they got like choppered out and
they had special SUVs it's like they
just leave the people who paid to be
there like leave them on deserted on
Island yeah but I guess if I was in the
situation and like GA I probably
wouldn't be scrambling I'd be head of
the pack yeah I'd be knocking down
fences myself however if I had a little
bit of you know hindsight it may think
maybe we just wait it out cuz then if
you wait like 30 minutes the place will
clear itself out but I guess it's like
you just walk one of those coming so if
you wait you're getting caught in the
storm but they were ready in the storm
they were waiting to see like they only
all left not because it was stormy
Webster
but because they canceled the act well I
was in Murray Hill on one of the gut
ball days and I couldn't understand why
everyone around me was dressed like bust
am Tatiana and neon I didn't know it was
cut ball and just like you know
gathering what I what I saw the types of
people like maybe they needed to tough
it a little bit learn a few life lessons
stop going to festivals or third you
know I agree or you're 13 I went to the
ball two years ago because I did like a
a work thing I was working with the
branch like I had to go and I was like
you know what cool a music festival and
I remember looking behind me I'm like
the rolling hills like the most people
I've ever seen in my life and it was
like nothing was even going on I was
like this is a disaster I had like such
a detest for Gov ball except I think
it's an important fact I'd to mention
that I had the best barbeque chicken
sandwich of my life like maybe in like
like better than any yeah the best
barbecue chicken sandwich I've ever had
a cup all yeah that is an interesting
guy it was like this the bun was like
soaked with the barbecue sauce juice and
it's just like pulled chick and it was
so good I just feel as though that there
they oversell tickets like that they
should cut it in half I mean obviously
then they would make half the money but
people would just feel like a little two
times happier so yeah and then there's
also panorama that happens on Randall's
Island
I just don't [ __ ] with that Island
whatsoever me neither ever since they
cancelled Farnborough
oh yeah good to be bothered yeah truly
we're still upset no bowling in high
school the tennis team used to go to
Randall's Island right yeah green know
that you should go to one of those
Islands governors know it was like
Roosevelt something with an arm maybe
Roosevelt's Randall's well this is
skinny [ __ ] right guys no I just say
remember hating it cuz I felt excluded
in high school so like it's just still
pertinent cool people weren't on the
tennis team in high school you know but
like those skinny preppy [ __ ] you
know you know as they say just calling
you out no I said they weren't the only
ones the same high school for a year
what why once the same high school for
four years
no no but like we were only in there
together oh yes yes but I'm sad about oh
and I left all the cool people left as
well hmm
I was just trying to make you feel
better today
they feel left out because nobody cool
is on the tennis I'm just like dude all
like get in there Bostick and their
little skirts man you don't bust just so
never being like I don't you like just
stand Roosevelt Island yeah don't come
back yeah yeah I come back now they
actually did you supply on island it is
coming back which island was it um it
wasn't governess it wasn't Rikers so it
could only have been Roosevelt or
Randall's or Randall's it wasn't
Roosevelt that's like where people live
I think was Randall's people well they
could have a totally quick Roosevelt I
know but like it's not like um it's like
a resident you know you wanna go there
was Ellis I think it was Owney Randall's
I'm gonna go Randall's to that so I'm
saying that's why hey cut ball what are
you what's your guess Tony for sure for
sure for sure Coney there are so many
islands you know the island of Manhattan
is an island in of itself yes you know
what a Coney Island is like people are
like Coney Island like the ferris wheel
I'm like snow gowns like the beige have
you ever been to Coney Island it's like
literally like impoverished and there's
trash everywhere like it's literally it
is a symbol of like what happened to New
York it used to be like this great
island with like umbrellas like people
go to the beach like now it's actually
like a landfill yeah that's so sad I
don't think I've ever been oh my god are
you guys getting targeted on Netflix for
you'd like to watch what if yes oh my
god it's a Central Park five what's that
do you know what the Central Park five
is what is it Oh
crime thing yeah okay well in like the
80s
I watched the og documentary with the
real kids there were five kids who like
lived in in New York who got convicted
of killing this jogger even though there
was like literally no evidence against
them they were like totally been
bamboozled hoodwinked into like giving
false confessions like the police were
being so crazy
they spent 15 years in jail I think one
of the kids ended up killing themselves
and they got out because finally like
they someone realized like that these
five kids didn't do it and they sued the
city for like a hundred million dollars
they won they never got their money Bill
de Blasio said the first thing he was
gonna do as his acting mayor was one get
rid of the horse of carrot rides which
he didn't do and she'll make sure these
kids get their money I don't know if
they ever end up getting their money
that
like I fell off like following but
someone just they mean I think they did
like a dramatization of the whole thing
in it's Netflix movie that people are
obsessed with like I just can't get
myself to watch it because it's so
depressing but it's so I watched the og
documentary in one of my classes yeah I
remember just being really struck by the
story but also like the sadness like
really got to me and I just don't know
if I could watch it cuz I bet it's so
great you know yeah I just like the pit
is just so real I feel that I kind of
want to watch tonight sorry it's not
what if it's when they see us I'm
getting confused because they're also
promoting what if when they see yes
sorry sorry sorry I don't know enough
about it so maybe I'll watch it what's
what it that's just like it looks like
some blonde lady she like has powers I
don't know Harry Jeffery but they're
both like coming up I'm like the main
like top screen on Netflix for me got it
okay cool well our next story is really
exciting and they don't know if it's
news that you know yet therefore it's
news that you need to know the
commentaries have all said that the kids
ended up getting their money oh great
not enough though not enough 15 years in
jail dr. paul nassif is engaged oh wait
i saw this and then also this morning i
saw a picture of terry - for have you
seen him no he's leather he looks so
different like it's so crazy how so you
have to look at the picture okay I will
over the weekend dr. paul nassif
proposed to his girlfriend Brittany
patacas and of course she said yes the
proposal which took place on Saturday
June first occurred on the Duffy boat
that cruised about of Marina the II
personality shared a snippet of the
romantic moment with fans as he uploaded
footage of the proposal to his Instagram
quote this weekend I found out I get to
spend the rest of my life with my soul
mate 6119 a plastic surgeon wrote
alongside the video below hashtags she
said yes that's really cute I guess this
was like a big weekend for engagement
yeah Alex had Joe LaBelle got engaged I
saw I think Nate's got engaged
oh yeah do you watch the video of course
oh my god it was the fact that she threw
up the flowers and then he got down on
one knee like she really didn't know no
I know
and also just back to this Paul Masson
thing who's this girlfriend I think
she's just signed a statement from
Adrienne herself no I don't see a
statement from Adrienne uh I don't know
who his girlfriend is but she's like
super cute oh she
it's cute you know dr. paul nassif is
really aging well and he definitely get
some work done but he's looking a lot
better than his days on Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills I think he was so
[ __ ] miserable in his own life and
like he's insides were so ugly that it
was turning his outsides to me the same
gene Oni me know when people are so
unhappy like it starts to take a toll on
their physical appearance I think Paul
and acid is in such a good place now
emotionally like he has a girlfriend a
fiancee he's got a hit show he's no
longer in this like awful marriage like
I think it's really starting to affect
his outer appearance like the happiness
is beaming from the inside I agree but
he's also like I think he's always just
kind of look the same but now he's like
good looking in an ugly way you know
yeah also like when you get like super
rich and famous like it just makes you
hotter yeah a big star lot just like
such like a weird show that like it just
I feel like it's never gonna get
canceled but it's not like the biggest
show ever
no and when I was reading this story
like I first I'm thinking I don't watch
botched all the time so it doesn't sound
tough as my minute first something like
oh a Jim Lewis ex-husband is engaged
like cool that someone wrote it up but
I'm like no he's like a big star
arguably bigger than her for sure and
like boch eyes I don't know in its sixth
season you know what I watched yesterday
relatively not and live oh how was it so
good they're family at first I was like
I really care about that I just want to
see them in LA doing their makeup like
this whole like simple life concept of
them going back to Vancouver I don't
know if that's gonna do it for me and
it's not that but their family's so
interesting and they're like parents are
such precious gems like it has so much
heart and soul and I really think it
could go the distance Wow okay so that
is my like official endorsement I mean I
wanted to like it regardless but like
there was a few times I could have cried
like it was really it had a lot of heart
according to some of the toasters Paul
Nassif's new fiance is in the surgery
business as well and they met at a
plastic surgery conference I mean I want
to go to a plastic surgery conference
yeah like not only maybe fine like a
sugar daddy but also like someone to do
my botox for free no totally and just
like consult have you heard about
seeking arrangements I mean I've heard
about it in like a jokey way like sugar
daddy he's looking for baby yeah but
like it's a very real thing in like a
lot of toasters do it I've heard because
like I'm just in some groups watching
people do it they're like and they don't
have to do anything sexually they just
like go out and dates and like they have
a good time like sometimes the guys
nicely like it cars and stuff it's one I
think like snitch needs a sugar daddy
would be a perfect sugary if you need J
seeking arrangement situation and to do
you watch movie I told you to watch new
romantic or whatever no oh but I did
watch always be my baby
the rom-com and I are you gonna watch it
it's not your babies oh it is the movie
I told ya I wasn't tryin to give away
too much but you should watch it was
really good but did you I do plan on
watching oh wait hang my baby okay
because I have many thoughts but I'll
save it to last night I saw it on
Netflix I wanted to watch it but Zach
was helping I'm watching Kanye and David
Letterman and you talked about that Oh
glad oh wow incredible
okay incredible and I just love seeing
Kim and Kanye behind the scene riding
but I really couldn't get past the David
Letterman up at all because he was being
so weird and I liked it in the beginning
I was really like you know he was
addressing like how nervous he is
because conni really excuse me he's like
this figure um he was being so weird
just like all this money for breakfast
like the most weirdest questions like I
keep like honestly like if I wasn't so
interested in Kim and Kanye I would have
turned it off immediately I can't
believe that the show has any success
does it I think it does cuz he gets like
huge guests obviously the what do you
eat for breakfast like wasn't so weird
to me he was just trying to get Kanye
talking because like I feel like for
Crimea it's like he doesn't have to say
anything like he's saying the minimum
until he gets going yeah um but I just
thought like at times he was really
condescending okay um not even in like
such an outright way but just like I
don't know when the the fact of like the
audience applause like was just like
really her factor yeah um I absolutely
loved when Kanye dressed him he looked
incredible looks a lot better he looked
so cool like I was I just love like
learning more about easy because it's so
crazy for so long like I feel like so
many people didn't take it seriously
myself included yeah Kanye and his sweat
pants and it's like $300 biker shorts
now when you look at the runway
presentation for like season 2 or season
3 it's like that is what everyone looks
like today it's really so crazy yeah so
um also I had one more thought that I
thought was important
oh just learning a lot more about his
upbringing like he said like people
weren't taking me seriously because like
I didn't grow up the way that like a lot
of other people in the industry did like
and I was wearing a collared shirt
at the VMA it's like I thought that was
so funny and I didn't really say like
how was upbringing was just like
different and as mom was a professor
here they traveled to Africa totally and
I also didn't realize that he was a
producer for so long and that he was
saving his own songs and then when I'm
so glad they got to the church pardon I
feel like I really have a better
understanding and me not church Sunday
services I have a better understanding
of like what they're doing there and I'm
obsessed me too and I'm glad that they
[ __ ] filmed inside of it yeah and you
know what
I never realized that Connie likes sung
like I know like it's not right yeah
yeah do you see the video of Nick Lachey
singing Moana no no it's okay it's good
it was cute he like did a balance to the
point of it but he was like singing with
his guitar player a match above Moana
and happier
I like harbor a lot of resentment the
best deal is you know okay I hover a lot
of resentment when it comes to cliche
why because I like personally identified
with Jessica Simpson where birthday
buddies we like and when I was growing
up like I really clink to the fact like
July times we had the same birthday like
she was really an icon like singing
angels instead and I just really felt
like the way that they broke up like was
so sad and like they didn't get a fair
chance and then like two seconds later
he moved on with Vanessa Lachey and like
now they're so happily married and I
just really like feel like him and
Jessica like didn't get a chance I agree
that's how I feel about keeping
Humphreys yeah yeah like I just feel
personally invested in this relationship
because I thought for a while like that
I was Jessica Simpson ya know we've
definitely a blow for everyone when like
it didn't work out and then like his
rebound turned into be his soulmate
that's the worst so I just like every
time I hear Nicolas yeah like I'm not
gonna like I roll my eyes a little bit
just cuz I feel personally victimized by
him no I was ready to roll my eyes but
then I'm like okay he's singing Moana
like that's a cute choice also he sings
yeah he's he's oh town 98 degrees
Oh town Lincoln for sure but like you
know none of those people can really
sing
you know but that's exactly what that's
the only thing they could do it was like
a diamond heist extra TV here's had the
weirdest no that's Mario Lopez yeah but
negligee like does some thirsty hosting
some toasting I don't know but I think
Vanessa Lachey is now gonna be in the
90210 reboot is news that I that I
bypassed this morning well I don't know
I'm just like I'm not like so here for
them just yeah no me neither but it
wasn't interesting but he has something
put it in the toasters and I was just
like thinking like I know you know what
was interesting video you know made me
think of it as like I feel like he wants
to go to Sunday service Oh totally you
know what was an interesting video
JLo backstage with her daughter singing
Alicia Keys have you seen that video
no I guess like July no I haven't J Lo's
daughter like is getting into singing
and she was back in some room with the
piano playing uh what's that song no I
can't have you know and her daughter is
a great boy since she was just being
like a supportive mom like not like
stealing the spotlight probably cuz she
can't sing and it was really interesting
and I enjoyed it and I wonder if Alicia
Keys in jail Oh get along cuz we're not
like more I carry into a low don't get
along look Alicia Keys gets along with
everyone I mean she's just such a
peaceful person yeah agreed well next
story it's hurtful influencers you don't
follow will soon be in your Instagram
feed great you may soon spot influencers
or you don't follow in your Instagram
feed on Tuesday the Facebook own photo
sharing platform announced it is rolling
out what it calls quote branded content
ads
this will allow brands to make
influencer sponsored content posts
appear as ads so a bigger audience sees
them that already happens I was just
gonna say I've seen that many times
businesses will be able to place these
ads in the Instagram feed in the coming
weeks and in stories in the next few
months
when branded content ads appear they
look similar to regular ads but users
will see the words paid partnership and
the brand's name on the bottom oh he's
just more even more streamlined also
it's like any if a Brandon and influence
are doing a partnership and they use the
paid partnership tool I guess it's like
that whole post is being used as an ad
got it that's cool actually I guess so
but like I just don't want to see
I don't follow I just don't want to see
like branded content on Instagram that
I'm not personally subscribed to yeah
we're like Brandon continent oh here's
of the brand set you were passed up for
yeah right here skip pains you didn't
receive that's hilarious and it's like
if it's targeted towards me it's like
because I would be a good fit right
right like you're the ideal consumer and
possible partner no that's so true I
also want to use this out as an
opportunity to talk about the 36 shirts
I knew you were gonna say it because
they really wanted to talk about that as
a story everyone wrote about but she's
so embarrassing that she's gonna get any
press for her merch but you got
president she sold 36 shirts
she's an influencer she hits like two
and a half million followers what's her
name re re she like launched a merged
company or like a clothing company and
she was like hyping it up on Instagram
for like months she finally launched it
and then like a couple weeks later she
did a follow-up post with a long caption
explaining I know I want to read it
because she deleted the initial post but
um everyone screenshot of it okay here
we are
hi as many of you have seen my brand I'm
sorry what as many of you have seen my
brand failing on its first job has
gotten a lot of buzz and I wanted to
clear a few things up first
I never even sold t-shirts so I have no
idea where that came from the minimum
wasn't 36 products I had to sell it was
36 of each product and I had seven
different products so I had to sell 252
pieces for my first drop parentheses
very hard I've also never bought
followers within the four years I've
been on social media every follower has
been earned over time your fans grow out
of being fans I never had the thought in
my head that me having followers meant I
was gonna sell out I knew that wasn't
the case and I mentioned that before I
don't need anyone's sympathy who
everybody trying to use pity to sell
more next time I shared my failure
because I've always kept it real with my
followers and I wasn't going to hide in
the shadows about this no she shared her
failure she was like shaming her
followers and the other follower and at
the other influenced them influencers
that support her for not supporting her
the most shocking and like entitled part
of this captionist her coming after like
influencer like people that she sent PR
to that didn't post about it like who
the [ __ ] are you
look you just demand by the way the the
when you send out PR the intention is
that it's never for the person to post
but like if they do great so said
get out with the intention of making
everyone posted out into a swipe up is
so inauthentic
yeah no the whole thing was we're not on
the one hand I'm like damn this [ __ ] is
brave for saying like that she failed
but on the other hand she was also just
trying to call everyone out and I'm I'm
just like grateful that we have this
story and I wouldn't I said that she
sold 36 shirts and that she's not even
gonna fulfill those orders because the
company that she partnered with you have
to sell a certain amount for them to
back you and like help with the
manufacturing and since she did it they
cancelled the entire company and all the
36 orders yeah so it's just like really
sad and I'm really interesting back to
it for the influence their business and
this season it's a state this is
something that we've been saying for a
long time and then I was looking at her
profile she's two and a half million
flowers she gets a lot of likes it's not
like her followers are fake she's
engagement but it's like the people who
are following her it's just there's a
difference between like following to
like or just like she's a cute girl with
like you yellow with an interesting life
or interesting influence or trips that
she goes on like that doesn't mean I'm
gonna buy a shirt no and I've been
saying this for years like when I was on
the corporate panels like literally
nobody nobody listens to me be like
would you rather partner with an
influencer twist 10 million followers
and no transaction in their audience
like the audience like there are people
who have audiences that are so
transactional like they care so much
about what the person is wearing but
they're doing like and and they know how
to monetize that or you're just like a
celebrity I'm like literally nobody
cares what it is they're just looking
you know yeah so it's like you can
partner with someone 100,000 followers
and there's like 10,000 people who
really give a [ __ ] or ten million
followers and literally nobody cares
thirty-six t-shirts ya know or it's like
you can partner with someone who has
like two million followers he gets the
same amount of likes as someone who has
two hundred thousand yep totally the two
hundred thousand person is probably
cheaper and I'm in the like the toastie
blog or a group of like bloggers you
follow and like the obsession with
certain bloggers is so real and like
that's just a real good indication of
like certain people who have audience
like positive or negative who have
audiences who are just like obsessed
with them you know I was actually
thinking about this recently I forget
why maybe it was because of re I've seen
we should make it to a patron episode
about like spon con hmm cuz I just think
it's such an interest short should I
feel like we have so much expertise many
people are just interested by okay so
head over to the patreon.com slash the
morning toast and join our toast after
dark Facebook group will gather some
questions about spawn con right let me
not fancy new microphones that I want to
try
yeah exciting okay that final story
before I step out so you can turn mouse
Joe Broz oh and we have deer toasters
say Oh our PA our PA and she also just
reminded us of it dear trusters is our
advice segment you can email us dear
toasters at gmail.com would keep it
anonymous anything from wedding drama to
work drama the weirder the better though
like that girl who's dating a guy who
donate sperm for fun like that's [ __ ]
interesting um so hit us up dear
toasters at gmail.com we promise to keep
it anonymous
I mean promise to keep it [ __ ] lit
you know she puts the APA yes she puts
this she puts the assistant production
assistant yeah okay let's go iTunes is
over oh yeah
what this means for you will my iPod
still work what if I use Windows don't
worry the closure of Apple's music app
will not bulldoze your library Apple is
closing iTunes this autumn but don't
panic the change means less than it
sounds your music is safe and iTunes
isn't really going away for good what is
happening this autumn Apple will release
the latest version of Mac OS 10.15
Catalina Wine Mixer named off an island
off the coast of La it really is called
Catalina just not the one it's just not
the Wine Mixer part which is their
[ __ ] cross to bear and truly the
update weather here's something so funny
what what I think of when I think of
Catalina Wine Mixer
what so Ben sister Maddie when she's in
high school her Instagram bio was it's a
[ __ ] Catalina Wine Mixer she got in
trouble because she had the f-word like
I'm super funny that is really [ __ ]
Catalina Wine Mixer
and that's literally like our cross to
bear the update will come with a raft it
changes to Mac apps including the
long-awaited demise of iTunes I have not
been weighted to this I [ __ ] they're
basically gonna launch three apps
instead of iTunes like it'll be like a
podcast app which I already have a movie
app and a music app right yeah something
like that yeah TV TV instead of movie
which they already have so I guess they
don't all like just here so unnecessary
like there was literally nothing wrong
with our - I know I should use the
[ __ ] [ __ ] Excel is the [ __ ]
I mean I've so many memories about
getting in trouble for mom like over our
199 charges like every month like
getting in so much trouble that we blame
her credit card I mean when it
from 99 cents a song to 1:29 it was I
changed everything that was [ __ ]
monstrous them no keeping it under
tolerance that's when they started going
down the tubes
the more than used to do is saw a free
song every week no yeah they used to
like give out one free song every week
it was like a new and up-and-coming
artists like it was just so brilliant
yeah and then like a dual engine I'm
like the sale rack my tunes like that
was really like a low in your career I
remember seeing like Jesse James Decker
their wants being like wow that is shred
chic they was telling your whole album
for six dollars she's on idea she's on
iTunes that's so true and honestly like
some of her music deserves like a second
chance no one I feel as though like
anyone can be on Spotify right now yes I
mean I'm not anyone could be on I when I
realized my single soon I'm gonna be on
spot but not anyone could be on iTunes
that's true as he'd a record label yes
so it was like just it was an exciting
time for music I don't think that Apple
music is half of what I use used to be
um and that's their cross to bear and I
guess this just cements my love for
Spotify anymore
did you okay so that's that dear
toasters Before we jump into your
toasters do you have trouble coming up
with gift ideas for the men in your life
every single day this should be your
toaster yeah my man's because he doesn't
like anything and the Father's Day just
around the corner most of us have some
shopping to do not maybe because my dad
died and let's face it the shopping for
guys is so not easy it's actually
impossible it's impossible Ben is
impossible to shop for if you haven't
already found the perfect gift you have
to check out swanky badger comm they've
got the most amazing personalized gifts
for the men in your life Father's Day is
all about showing Dad how much he's
loved and appreciated and nobody does it
better than swanky badger are you gonna
get Ben a gift for Father's Day because
he's how there's a--they oh thank you
for asking seeing as how I didn't even
get so much as a card for Mother's Day
no okay
everything they have is super practical
so there's something for everyone
wallets phone cases watches whiskey to
Canter's but the most amazing thing is
how personal and sentimental you can
make any gift for example on their
wallets you can engrave a message on the
inside telling dad how much he's loved
and appreciated maybe a message for the
kids and he gets to read what every
message he gets to read that message
every single time see he opens his
wallet the process is super easy you
just choose the gift you want type in
the message you like engraved and it
lands on your doorstep fully customized
in just a few days you can create your
own personalized Father's Day gift today
by going to swanky badge
komm forward slash toast and you'll get
10% off your first purchase
that's swanky badger swanky SWA NK why
badger badg er comm slash toast and make
sure to check out the video of all those
guys crying it's honestly the sweetest
thing you'll ever see
swanky badger comm slash toast do you
know how hard it was to get through that
room it's like out shedding a tear
Oh like you know like oh but you should
do it for Ben's dad for like oh that's
like gonna [ __ ] the bed on a gift oh for
sure the dependent still works like dick
okay I'm gonna brunch for Father's Day
okay bye honey have a good times like
okay I'm gonna set up a Bloomingdale's
first get a gift like he is such a bad
son no tell me that Spanky Bachelor calm
I'm going to that's a great idea
wanky bad we just love the word swaggy
are you playing up to your toasters or
should I Oh actually you know I actually
like reading them I like when you read
them I like being a listener
I love experiencing it tonight put it in
a doc doc she's so cute because she puts
the imba well this is long okay do your
toasters I have a work situation that is
well quite interesting I'm currently a
first-year associate at a mid-sized law
firm my office is very professional when
it comes to getting our jobs done but
also very casual and cool I wear my TMT
sweatshirt to work on the Reg and we
even have a couch designated for
drinking purposes however there's one
situation that I learned about Raceland
that has placed me in a bit of a
predicament for context purposes
generally in a law firm environment
every first-year associate has to report
to a managing attorney or a partner in
my situated under son no I haven't heard
that okay why I just sounded familiar
maybe someone else named their their
mysterious boss named Bob I think that's
a class yeah I don't think there's one
situation that I learned about reason
that has placed me in a little bit of a
predicament for context purposes in a
law firm environment every first-year
associate has to report to a managing
attorney in my situation I have to
report to my boss my boss who we will
call Bob Bob and I are extremely close
since we spend every day together I
talked about as if he was my cool uncle
and get advice ranging from
relationships to what kind of car to buy
however we say Bob over shared some very
personal information with me myself Bob
and another attorney went out to dinner
together after a late night of working
in the office the drinks were flowing
and we were talking about everything in
anything
at one point I told Bob hey let me find
you a girlfriend and he replied slightly
buzzed I have plenty of girlfriends
let's just say when I found out that my
boss Bob is a swinger and has a fetish
for very very large women oh my god he
even showed us a fetish app he uses and
told us all about the women he was
currently talking to I was Chuck to my
[ __ ] court when I heard this
bob is tall skinny nerdy white guy and
then P proceeded to tell us that he has
sexy time with these women at our office
on our beloved drinking couch as the
conference table he rotates between four
to six women a week he always know we
always knew Bob liked to stay late at
the office and came in on the weekends
but we thought it was for work purposes
ever since Bob divulged his love life he
continues to share his stories with me
I'm generally open to listening because
the stories are like a bad car wreck you
just can't stop listening and the past
week I've noticed that Bob has been
absent from the office more than usual
and today my fellow co-workers asked me
where bob was and how he's never here
during the day some of the co-workers
even think he's got cancer or some
ailment that is causing him to go to
doctors appointments but in reality is
out having an afternoon romp I don't
know what to do about the situation I
don't feel uncomfortable with his sexy
time adventurous because he's extremely
respectful and an amazing boss but I
feel like it's truly affecting work the
other day my female boss approached me
about the situation because she knows
also and she told me he has expressly
she told me she has expressly told him
he's not allowed to engage in this
behavior at the office hours I told her
they need to have a conversation I
didn't need to be left out of it I truly
feel stuck in the middle because I see
Bob's side in my female bosses
perspective but there could be a huge
fallout with Bob which could affect my
job because I'm his associate please
help what do I do
okay that really took a turn if anything
I was with Bob like it should not affect
your job so don't worry about that I
think it's like it's this woman has
issues with him and what he's doing like
that it's her cross to bear if it
doesn't bother you know like stay the
hell out of it and just keep skating
mentality in most things but
specifically work thing is like it's
nothing it's not your business like I am
so just interested in other people's
lives like I'm too self-involved to like
really give a [ __ ] about anyone else
that like it almost works in my favor
because I'm never inserting myself into
things that like don't belong to me and
I
especially in the workplace like insert
yourself as less as possible if people
stop asking questions if you're just
like not involved yeah so like pretend
like you don't know and it's really at
the desk unless it really starts to
bother you and like it just doesn't feel
right like then maybe do something about
it but as long as like Bob's a good dude
he likes what he likes web pop live ya
know I'm like honestly the fact that Bob
like opened up tea was really sweet he's
not doing anything you know just the
only problem is that he's doing it
during work hours boy please you're
watching the toast during work hours who
are you to judge right oh so and like I
thought this story was gonna go south
when he was telling you about these
things like I was like oh my gosh she
sounds uncomfortable is why people
should not who work together should not
drink together yeah um but no it was all
good she seems understanding and cool
like just I think just stay the [ __ ] out
like yeah it's not your business and
like don't you kiss Young's you know
agree and it's like a key word leaving
work all the time it's like have sex
with his wife would it be an issue right
and his wife knows about it because he's
a swinger he's desiiva why he doesn't
have a wife he says he's a swinger I
think he's six like she was like I want
to set you up with someone and he was
like no I have six girlfriends oh right
right right right
so he's like single but he's just
leaving to have sex so it's like this is
what he prefers but say he was doing
what you would consider normal would
anyone have an issue with it you tell
him Jackie do stigmatize there's a date
like oh this is honest about it what do
you do at night you know I know I feel
like there's a few sayings that can
apply to every dear groceries um denied
your business like don't involve don't
take it to HR take it HR and doing up
your owns yeah let's see where the next
category to do you toasters I would like
to start by giving a little backstory my
boyfriend and I had been together for
six years his mom and I have never
really seen eye-to-eye
she's a helicopter mom I mean she hovers
and she's very controlling and bossy
she's very protective of her family she
has never been my favorite person but
we've always gotten along and been civil
my boyfriend's dad left and moved when
he was little and his mom is was in and
out of rehab I've always been interested
in my boyfriend's background since he
doesn't know much about his father I
once asked his mom what my boyfriend's
background is in her response was he's
American and gave an eye-roll America
phalaris
so when 23andme came out I bought my
boyfriend a kit because we were both
generally interested in what it would
show okay she's like so like like
smoothie yeah we got his results and not
much cheese contest and well we got this
results and not much more came from it
well fast forward two weeks
my boyfriend got an email through
23andme it was a woman reaching out who
said she was adopted her adoption was
closed and she doesn't know anything
about her parents 23andme had my
boyfriend listed as her niece and this
woman thought that she might be a
sibling of one of my boyfriend's parents
my boyfriend told me he would forward
the email to his mom to see if she knew
anything the next day my boyfriend's mom
calls my boyfriend and tells him that
she has a secret my boyfriend's mom
tells my boyfriend oh she's like
speaking without name so it's like so
boyfriend my boy was mom then I'd say my
boyfriend's mom calls my boyfriend and
tells him that she has a secret my
boyfriend's mom tells me that 15 she had
a baby and gave the child up for
adoption the only people who know are my
boyfriend's mom's siblings and her now
deceased parents my boyfriend's mom has
never told my boyfriend or his siblings
or her husband who she has been married
to for over 20 years my boyfriend's mom
asked my boyfriend not to say anything
to anyone of course he told me and says
that she plans on telling the rest of
the family in person my boyfriend's
sister lives in an apartment in a
different state and currently does not
have plans to come visit so I think she
is stalling she does and she wants to do
it when they are all together which only
happens on major holidays at Christmas
and Thanksgiving on top of this my
boyfriend's new half-sister and her
daughter have sent my boyfriend multiple
23andme messages saying they want to
connect and find out more information
about their family and it breaks my
heart each message I read and my
boyfriend has continued to ignore them
he says each time he he asks his mom
about it she gets upset and doesn't want
to push things and he doesn't to push it
anymore do I have to sit and wait it out
I feel bad and they keep pressuring my
boyfriend to ask his mom questions but
it's so unfair that he doesn't get the
opportunity to know his siblings or his
family thanks for all your help and
advice sincerely one impatient
girlfriend I have a lot of thoughts and
like honestly they're really negative
about the person who wrote it and she
seems so nosy like it's so not your
business and first of all your boyfriend
doesn't even seem like that passionate
about like one way or other like you're
swaying in whichever way you feel it's
like the mom went through something
really traumatic giving up a child like
how she chooses to handle it as her
business isn't like tea for the toasters
now right no but but it's like this is
like something that the daughter the
moms going through and if the son was
like beating really impatient like
wanted to know and like was really
invested like I would say it's on the
mom to like get involved and like start
moving things around but it's like your
son's girlfriend is being annoying and
it's like buzz off yeah
seriously bust the [ __ ] off the only one
who cares her ones answers is her family
but no so if they were married she would
have liked a little bit more of a leg to
Santa but not even that not even then
like it's so deeply personal and like
she's being [ __ ] starters yeah
she's being Lisa Rinna and I'm just like
I don't approve oh my god I know I know
I the mom whirls her eyes at her Jackie
I have to tell you something okay
so you know how a while ago Ben was
talking about like if he was a housewife
who would he be and you said he was Lisa
Rinna and he got so offended so him and
I were at 40 karats like a week ago and
we were just talking about the list of
where the things we're going we were
just talking about the Lisa Rinna thing
and then like I was talking about
something else and he was like why did
you just say that and I'm like he said
what's wrong and like it was just a
random conversation I'm like what are
you talking about him I literally just
having conversation he's like no but
like you're like what happened he was
being so dramatic I'm like Sabrina like
he was literally trying to make
something out of this conversation I was
having I was like I'm just saying I'm
like I don't even know what it's about
like the same it's about work I was like
you know and then like we you know we
wrapped up the show he was like but why
and I was like why are you being so
[ __ ] madness I was like you're being
Lisa Rinna right now and he really
understood he was like wow I am Wow and
I said it you said it I meant to talk
call you like right at that meal that is
so funny this is our third and final two
your toasters reminder if you want to
submit something cool and weird - dear
toasters - toasters at gmail.com
hey girls and the PA will find them
let's get into it
I'm a very late twenties gay man but I'm
most most importantly I'm a toaster love
what a great intro happy Pride Month I
really recently started seeing this guy
who I'm incredibly into it we met online
on an app that is basically for hooking
up so the fact that I got something with
substance of it is a miracle in and of
itself this gentleman who let's call
Bradley is just so perfect I would never
have thought I'd be into someone like
him I'm more Bravo he's more Discovery
Channel oh my god I love that that uh
comparison and I can't believe how much
of a perfect fit it is so Bradley and I
have been hanging out for a month now
consistently you've had sleepovers make
dinners for each other I cheered him on
at a sporting event Bradley had to
reschedule plans once I played it cool
not uncool but with how I felt but how I
felt processing that we weren't hanging
out after looking forward to it all day
I knew how hard I was into him I'm
basically living in Tyler riches the
difference I don't get that
I'm trying so hard not to be desperate
desperado but I want things to be
officially official so bad I've adopted
the mantra just enjoy the ride because
we are having fun making memories and
it's been so great Bradley shows mutual
signs of being into me and while we
enjoy a few spicy margaritas he said
after the first time we hung out he was
up all night thinking about me
I know his amazing potential but I need
to chill for a bit as two business
women's specials who were very in tune
when the hell is it appropriate time
that I can bring up the are we
boyfriend's questions sincerely
hopefully missing puzzle piece Bradley
didn't even know he was missing okay I
think after a month of consistently
seeing each other it is an appropriate
time but there are also steps like once
you see each other I think you have to
officially like stop seeing other people
and that's a great segue to boyfriends
but simply sometimes people get like
free time by variables you have to say
are we seeing other people under net
that conversation might turn into are we
boyfriends but like I remember the day
and but also it's like if you're seeing
someone for a month but it's only been
like once me week and you've only seen
them now four times second right it's
not time but if you've been seen I'm
like almost every day time I was like
it's time I remember when Ben asked me
to stop seeing other people I was like
for sure and like I didn't ask me was my
boyfriend but I just assumed didn't like
a day later he was like everybody found
I'm like okay so just having the
conversation of like are we gonna still
see other people is a great segue to
hopefully get to the place you wanted to
be but like sometimes also anyway like
get the answer you're not looking for
like when Zack and I started dating like
we hung out every single day so it was
like we obviously weren't seeing other
people because there was no time and
then I remembered and he asked me to be
his girlfriend I was like nothin have I
not been wide use meet my mom right I
let you into my house like you're not
even my boy like like you had dinner in
my family I remember he like asked me on
the day that he like he was like I think
was like the fourth of the month and
something with them number four he just
like wanted that to be our anniversary I
was like that's not how it works
you know just get to like [ __ ] and
choose your anniversary you know like
throw it no our anniversary is the day
that we started like that we you know
hit it off that night at the with you
guys yeah well now our anniversary is
our wedding but I was like no don't just
write to like no it's so funny before we
got married me and Ben had 1,000
anniversaries you know the day we were a
girlfriend the day we said I love you
the day we became exclusive our
engagement now it's like we got one
September 17th please get me a present
yeah that's nice
yeah we're just wedding anniversary now
but it's nice to celebrate like your
anniversary of getting engaged like just
between the two of you but it's like you
don't have to take off work to telling
your planet trip no definitely no taking
work um okay so are you gonna see
yourself out oh I'm gonna see myself out
or just switch seats with a snitch no no
you don't want to hear these others
recap I am going to get a lights Mackie
oh oh if you come back to weed you bring
me a snack oh I'll take a cream cheese
schmear and maybe an orange juice Jackie
start okay I'm so excited so they're
changing so podcasters just hang on
hello snitch do you need this microphone
Margo is here you learned we are going
to discuss the Jonas Brothers
documentary Jason came out last night I
watched it I love totally erotic though
I have so many thoughts I feel like I
know so many things now and the main
thing that I know is that Nick Jonas
it's just like here okay
same but you know what I really was
looking for clarity on in terms of the
documentary that I didn't get um and I
thought I was gonna get because they
never really discussed how it went from
being like Nick's band to being Joe's
band because from the get-go it's very
clear like Nick is the musically
inclined when like he really like had a
passion and he was driving to the city
and he was on Broadway and like his
brothers kind of copied him yeah I mean
they were all really talented but it was
like Nick's thing and they said I
thought they were gonna address it
because they said when they were on that
minivan tour before they found out he
had diabetes they were like and keep in
mind they said at this point it was very
much Nick's bad yeah that's what I was
gonna say so I thought they were
eventually gonna address how they got to
the place of it being Joe's band
and it seems like it was the Disney of
it all that made it the Joe Joe's band
yeah Brock camp rock um but they never
really explained how that dynamic shift
definitely hurt Nick's feelings and he's
kind of entitled to that feeling but I
mean I don't know if that's the truth
because they didn't say and I feel like
they really made a commitment in this
documentary to be like completely
transparent and open like when they did
that z100 like a radio show thing like
and Kevin like obviously has been torn
up about it for years
oh my god I'd always know about
was really brave like and I just thought
they were being so open but they left
have this big chunks that I think a lot
of people are wondering like I think
Nick is like a little bit of a diva I'm
like him not being in the center of the
stuff like was making him I feel like
Nick thinks that he is like literally
God's gift to this work like earth and
like Joe honestly like he has a better
voice and he's like a better rockstar
don't know that Joe released an R&B
album me neither I'm just trying to go
find it and I also didn't know what
album were they talking about when they
said that they like when the Jonas
Brothers right before they broke up they
like got back to getting lines lines and
trying times before the storm but he's
on lines lines yeah oh I don't know then
I looked it up and yeah they think he
might have been lying signs but Heinlein
was so interesting and if you really
think about it like their mega Fame was
so short-lived and also when Joe was
like when they broke up he's like I was
25 26 and I didn't really know she was
like you were 25 26 how old are you now
yes 29 so I think he might have been
wrong cuz I looked it up they broke up
in 2013 yeah and like the Kevin of it
all really made me sad he said and you
know what I was thinking about it's like
a bald like they all got famous at such
different ages but I think the worst age
was for Kevin because he never really
had like a normal teenage time where's
like Kevin I mean Nick and Joe like got
to be famous at when they were 18 and
like yet girls where's like Kevin was
getting bullied when he was like 17 18
you know Sam he's like really I feel
like stunted in his growth yeah and like
the band took a lot away from him but
that's when he got married so early and
like I just I totally understood what
Joe was saying when he was explaining
himself for yeah for the reality I think
he was like I never imagined like
putting anything before the band like
the band was my life and was like you
found love and like I get that now do
anything for Sophie but like I literally
rewound 800 times she was like I don't
do anything for like a [ __ ] hour with
Sophie I said I might have died I died
it was so cute um but I think there's
more like in terms of the dynamic yeah
Nick um even though it kind of seemed
like Joe and kept Joe and Nick wanted to
go out on their own together right but
so I was always thinking that it was
like Joe and Nick were like buddies and
then Kevin was like kind of third but
then even in the opening scene there was
like that weirdness between Nick and
Kevin I was like oh I mean that nobody
seen
it was being so mean kevin is obviously
like trying to talk and trying to be a
confrontational like in a not mean way
and it was like just say it like you
were afraid to confront me yeah yeah
dick Kevin's nice oh my god
Kath honestly like during set fourth of
July party at the end of it I was like
hey like I love Joe so much he's my
favorites not kids we stand no Joe he
looks like sloppy and like not cute like
Nick like I don't even know where what
land he looks like he was from and then
Kevin just looks like this like hot buff
like American dude and it was like wow
like Kevin is so hot okay also can we
please talk about how Miley Cyrus
changed Nick Jonas his life and in that
clip of them singing on stage away he
looked at her I was like I didn't know
that I know it's actually it's like
teenage love and like you totally think
it's like there was passionate really
when you're 16 but like they were really
making a lot of sense like and just
saying how like Nick was writing songs
and then like he was finally like
writing songs like of an experience he
now could relate to yeah and you know
that he wrote SOS like nobody else just
Nick you know what it's like he takes
himself so seriously and you could see
that even as a kid he did and now he
does too and like he really just thinks
he's above it and I'm really like so not
here for but I am here for him now being
put in this place yes it might truly
been humbled because he he broke up the
band Hebrew and you know what's so
interesting that I really wanted to talk
about is when they took those couple
years off and they like weren't really
hanging out with each other and like
kevin was having babies I remember
seeing Nick and Kevin and Kevin and Joe
Joe and Nick holding the babies and just
being like I feel like they're just I
remember thinking am i I mean I feel
like there's like a break like there I'm
like I don't even know Kevin and Joe
still hung out right and I kind of
appreciate the fact that they never
looked put on a fake [ __ ] on social
media they never pretended like they
were all best friends they kind of dated
me with the holding the baby that was
the first time I saw each other since I
broke up but it's nice you're not going
to not put a picture of your like I just
like that I knew it's a consumer that
there was like a break in the family and
they didn't pretend to be anything else
yeah you know I don't know the whole
thing just made me really not feel good
towards Nick Jim really just and also I
really want them to talk about Olivia
culpo like when they showed like the
jealous music videos give me like a
little glimpse yeah of Olivia no I mean
respect for Priyanka yeah but I just
so interesting like the whole thing I
just learned so many factoids about them
and their dynamic was just like oh my
god marker but I just kind of really
want oh the phone call but I really want
like Kevin and Joe to be like as close
as Joe and Nick meet you
92 I won I didn't know that Sofia and
Joe had a place in Australia I think
that was like a house that they have I
when he said it's my second one I was
like why and also what bronto because
it's closer to her yeah well me so much
joy was that like dnc he was like just
as big as Nick Margot and like I was
it's like when I was seeing him on stage
also like just like we were seeing Nick
on see yeah I was like [ __ ] yes but like
I feel like so competitive when it comes
to the solo careers of Nick and me too
Joe and I think it came a lot harder to
Joe because like he wasn't as creative
in terms of like behind the scenes
producing songwriting but he had such -
each present yeah whereas like Nick is a
weenie onstage and I think that's why he
was never made the lead singer of the
band but he like loved writing songs he
was a lead singer of the band until now
I think oh I think for sure Joe easily
say no wait when they were Nick back
then and I think it's Joe now oh I think
the total opposite I think when we were
like in high school like loving the
Jonas Brothers middle school whatever
like I think that it was Joe's band
really yeah I think it was Nick's man
and I think it's Joe's band now oh my
god I think now it's like they're all
being equal because so much of the
resentment was from like whose band it
was and that's what I think yeah I just
want to say justice for Kevin like that
whole thing he says like between they're
like are you Joe or neck oh and also
just like everything he was saying was
just like making me sad but honestly
like he kind of came out like the best
haunted house in New Jersey juicy that
his massive house in New Jersey like he
got in those years where like they were
all off like he got his life together as
a family now and like now he can move
forward in his career like knowing all
the personal stuff it's like taking care
of and like he you know any me like it
never hinder him like I think that was
so epic like as much freedom as well cuz
he's done the kids thing it's over now
Joe and Nick at some point are gonna
have to start having children and like
they're gonna become new fathers and
they can that takes to tell where as
much yeah no totally I like I'm I love
Kevin so much like that's also like
justice for the dad oh my god that was
so sad it felt like a Scientology
documentary when they were like the
church the church and the way that they
like music and zoomed on the trees in
the rain
yeah I knew that they were like
religious I didn't know that their dad
was a pastor I didn't know that the
purity ring thing literally broke them
up no I know and then they put the when
they were we were at sporting games and
the couple would would do us like it we
never spoke about like how much that
upset us yeah no I didn't know that it
took such a toll I thought that it was
like a funny thing but I guess you have
to think about those things sometimes
like how they affect the people that
you're great and like you think when
you're so famous like they wouldn't even
know that people are booing them but
like like it gets to that so they kept
saying it's like when you're aware of
like this joke that you're a part of and
also when the manager was like Nick came
in was like I'm 21 and I'm the husband
that was like that was true though that
was really what I didn't realize is that
they have so much more self-awareness
than I ever gave him credit for cuz they
grew up normal yeah they grew up so
normal like then what was so interesting
was how they really like attributed
their downfall to the second season of
Jonas and I totally understood that and
that was like giving me a pick it sounds
like you can be mismanaged and make one
mistake and it has like lifelong
impressions on your but I was thinking
that the whole time exact I never
realized it was two completely different
personas yeah the Jonas Brothers on
stage versus this Jonas shed this geona
show was so stupid but like I watched at
night like Tiffany they were so ready to
put appart but the plain one Kevin was
21 on Disney Channel and also just the
people they were portraying if they were
just being like the regular Jonas
Brothers on this reality show not
reality show TV show then it's different
but they were trying to be these that
cookie cutter likes my boys yeah it was
it was weird but overall I really liked
the documentary I appreciated how open
they were it did like not fulfill
exactly what I wanted it to because I
wanted to hear more from Nick no I
wanted to hear more about Nick from the
other two because they really feel like
Nick is the diva and it was the downfall
and if they and if they do break up
again like it will be on Nick
because I think he really has this like
this he takes himself so seriously and
he thinks that he's like way more
talented and deserves all the accolades
where it's like he had a great solo
career but like it wasn't even
comparable to what they are together
what was what I found in knowing was
like a whole hour in the movie was
really just about like the lead-up which
I enjoyed because somebody's going
dragon rock out there right like they
people think like they got a show on
Disney or whatever and like the
came huge overnight machines success
worth like no they were like touring on
the road like they really wanted it so
badly but they also needed it like their
whole family was riding on it and also
when Joe said like everyone thought it
was like this machine that they were
using a Christian above one who's like
and they were right yeah crazy I just
wanted to know how they all lost their
virginities and they didn't tend to him
yeah I think they don't miley yeah I
think that conversation with Danielle on
the phone with the tickets in the car
was they have so much footage I was
thinking I'm like well how do they have
it and even back then like camcorders
like they really have so much footage of
their lives yeah but I was think about
it with us I mean it's different cuz
it's technically like the digital age
and like we're always on our phones like
we have so much random footage show like
it's just like patreon videos now like
yeah it's like these videos so no defo
me never need to make a documentary we
have that phone call is wild wild also
me and Margaret going to the Jonas
Brothers album oh it's you know then
yeah you were chosen and we got plus one
they were kept strict I'm excited too I
just had one more thing left to say
rollercoaster the song the song they
played a couple songs that I think are
coming up and now they're something so
good but you know who wrote roller
coaster Ryan Tedder the whole albums
right I know but this one was like Ryan
Tedder I was actually thinking this
morning because Joe Jonas did a scram
story where he tagged Ryan Tedder and I
was like wow this Joe Jonas out I mean
this Jonas Brothers album like could be
like the unreleased One Republic album
yes any comes out Friday yeah okay I do
have to run because I'm so busy today
thank you guys for listening to the
morning toast we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time head over
to girl with no job comm particulates to
the dirty jeans tour this summer I'm
hitting up Richmond Virginia Virginia
Beach Vegas Labor Day weekend everyone
succumb to that and I just added a
second show in San Francisco so head
over to girl with no job comm get your
tickets thank you guys
love you ATS see you tomorrow
you